so if you ask me any time of year is a
good time for barbecue but especially
labor day weekend so we are turning to
chef bruce coleman from soul belly to
give us all the juicy tips chef thank
you so much for being here how are you
doing jillian good how are you i'm good
ready for the weekend me too and i wish
our viewers at home could smell this
right now because it smells amazing but
let's get right to it you've brought a
lot of stuff and you're working on
something over here yeah you know it one
of some of the great tips about you know
labor day and those barbecues is if you
do it low and slow you know an offset
smoker like now you know pellet smokers
are pretty readily available
you know you could end up with results
like this wow look at that juicy and
perfect but you can sit around and drink
a beer while you're doing it you know
what i mean and that it's the holiday so
that's the kind of celebration and to go
along obviously
oh yes you can handle that
okay look at this i don't know if you
guys can see it but look how perfect and
juicy this meat is the only thing that
would make it better is a good side to
go with it well we have a few of those
as well so i made a little fresh pasta
salad here um you know my background as
a chef is italian cooking so for our mac
and cheese for our pasta we actually
make fresh pasta you don't have to do
that at home but you know you can cook
some noodles it's just bright fresh
little parmesan red wine vinaigrette and
oregano we have our mac and cheese our
corn casserole uh coleslaw and then i
brought we make our own sausages
in-house so these are all things um you
know and if listen if you you're too
busy this weekend and you don't want to
cook at home we can take care of you
yeah so if we want to leave it to the
professionals you guys do catering and
the weekend is coming up quickly so
should people get their orders in now
yeah they have to we need them at least
48 hours in advance because we cook you
know a day before basically is when
we're smoking all the meats well and if
people decide to cook at home i'm not
the best but i want to try out some of
my specialties this weekend so how can
you amp up a side and just take it to
the next level you know i think uh
coming up with ideas like these you know
for example like this corn casserole you
can make it the day before you can make
it two days before and then reheat it um
we take this this is a honestly it's a
box mix that's my wife's recipe i love
it and i chef'd it up as she said and i
added we added hatch chili and some
cheddar cheese and some charred corn to
it so those are a few things that you
could do to it well there you go you
made our labor day grilling easy but i
might just come visit you and let you do
the cooking for me
well thank you so much jeff you guys are
located in the arts district so if
anyone wants to check it out i'm going
to enjoy some meat over the break and
we'll be right back